voilà la dernière technologie de caméra
sous l'écran de Samsung alors si vous
avez déjà regardé des smartphones de
Samsung notamment le Galaxy Z fold 4 et
le Galaxy Z folle de 3 bien évidemment
et bien l'intérieur vous aura pas
échappé qu'il y a une caméra sous
l'écran qui devient invisible lorsque
vous regardez du contenu lorsque vous
scrolez dans vos paramètres bref on voit
plus la caméra et lorsque vous venez
l'activer bien les biens là vous pouvez
vous prendre en photo alors pour autant
aujourd'hui les caméras sont pas des
résolutions de dingue à cet endroit là
elle travaille dessus bien évidemment
mais il travaille surtout à venir cacher
les caméras avec une densité de pixel
beaucoup plus élevée je l'ai vu
notamment chez ZTE avec leur nouveau
smartphone c'est vraiment intéressant on
la voit quasiment plus et ici ça me
saoule nous montre leur dernière
technologie en tout cas dernière
technologie qu'ils ont révélé j'imagine
qu'il travaille sur plein de techno qui
ne montrent pas je trouve ça cool de
pouvoir voir ici où on en est devant les
différentes étapes et j'ai hâte d'avoir
des caméras sous l'écran partout pour ne
pas me retrouver comme sur mon galaxy
S23 ultra à avoir cette énorme caméra en
haut et je trouve pas ça très très jolie
donc voilà donc ça c'est cool ça arrive
ça se développe Samsung display qui se
fait est-ce que vous vous êtes partisans
des caméras sous l'écran dites-moi si ça
vous botte oui ou non dans les
commentaires